John Smoltz in Major League Baseball
Network analyst part-time golfer and a
full-time hall-of-famer joining us on
the show you can watch John on MLB
tonight plus MLB Network exclusively
airing the Hall of Fame induction
ceremonies so his former teammate
Chipper Jones Jim Thome Vlad Guerrero
Trevor Hoffman Jack Morris Alan Trammell
that's Sunday beginning at 11:00 a.m.
Eastern Johnny how are you this morning
doing great doing great all right out of
that group you can draft who's your
first draft pick chipper told me you
know you're gonna take chipper all right
let's take chipper out of this Lee
Soto me Vlad Trevor Hoffman Jack Morris
Alan Trammell we're having a draft you
have first pick well I'm gonna be super
biased and I'm gonna go with the guy
that totally impacted me and that's Alan
Trammell in a way where I just have to
be biased to what he did for me when I
got drafted by the Tigers and hmm it
didn't seem like much you know at the
time for him to just be a gentleman I
was a fish out of water was scared to
death I I didn't I didn't you know these
are all the guys that I idolized growing
up and I got drafted and put in uniform
and and Miss rookie ball and trained
with the club for a month and he was
what I call passing on the baton he gave
me an opportunity to see what a big
leaguer was like and you know what at
the end of the day it changed me for the
way the way I handled everybody else
when I was in that position so I'm going
totally Maya super happy for Alan
Trammell classiest guy I've ever been
around and obviously now hall-of-famer I
just brought up Jimmy Garoppolo
verbalized that he thought when he was
in New England he was better than Tom
Brady
now his belief that he was better than
Tom Brady so his mindset was I'm better
than Tom Brady didn't verbalize it to
Brady or anybody else until recently
with bleacher report it if I asked you
back in the day were you the best
pitcher on your staff with Greg Maddux
and Tom Glavine in your mind what would
you've said regular-season no postseason
yes I really I was I was in awe of what
both of them did
to see Gregg come over and and make us
just an elite staff but I you know it's
like the same thing in golf you come up
against certain golfers and you go oh
geez geez I can't let this guy know that
he's way better than me and you had that
as a baseball player you know there's
probably only a couple people in the
game that can feel like they're the best
and there was no doubt in the
regular-season preparation all the
things that went into it they they just
seemed to be better prepared to win
games
of course I was always the guy with
stuff but then I really believed I was
the best player on the field come
postseason that was but that was my time
that I could feel that what'd you think
of the story Daniel Ponce de Leon the
Cardinal rookie comes back from brain
surgery throws seven no-hit innings that
fear of the comebacker did you ever have
one that you know one that you remember
now obviously not one as serious as this
but what's that like that comebacker
yeah you know I don't know about the
rest of the guys but you never think
about it until it happens you know I
mean you don't go out there going on you
know I got to make sure I don't pitch
this ball away or get hit you don't
really if you're thinking about it
you're in trouble as a pitcher and the
moment it happens you know then you
realize wow and you have to find a way I
first of all have all the admiration in
the world for this kid to wait what he
did I I was catching up on baseball
yesterday and I saw the line and I and I
just freaked out no hits and I think my
girls were looking at me like what do
you why is that such a big deal and they
didn't know the back story to this young
man so if that is so impressive because
he dealt with the extreme you know I got
drilled right under the collarbone in
spring training knocked me flat on my
back hurt for a week but nowhere does it
compare to up near you know the head
region and and to come back and do that
that's fantastic I just I can't even
imagine what he went through to get to
that point he's John Smoltz
hall-of-famer MLB Network
joining us Dan Patrick's ago your
reaction to the Brewers fans giving Josh
hater a standing ovation Saturday night
yeah you know it's what's interesting is
is when first of all it's the reason why
I don't have anything to write down and
to put into space but things that get
brought back what how many years later
yeah um seven years later so I remember
having a conversation when it first all
started with with my kids going it never
goes away oh yeah it does no it never
goes away somehow some way it'll be
brought back but I think seven years
later for all the things that people
have done to make mistakes I don't think
I don't think we would want to be 10
years from now going alright ten years
ago you did this so I think from
Milwaukee standpoint and one of their
own you know they they realized that
this was a long time ago and that he has
apologized and changed and did all the
necessary things but Wow seven years ago
to bring it up at that time was you know
I know in in life timing of when things
come out can be on purpose well we saw
that with the college basketball
championship Dante D Vincenzo he had
some tweets in the mid games somebody
released this on him so there there are
people are there to get you but you have
to give them an ammunition to get you
and both of these players certainly Josh
hater did Dodger fans getting Manny
Machado should think what big picture I
think they should think they're the
favorites I know you know one player in
the middle of the lineup with the
skillset that he has gives their offense
the legitimacy that you know let's say
Arizona had last year with JD Martinez
and especially the second half of that
last month that he went on this is a
this is what to me when everyone asked
me three months ago that I thought this
was the no-brainer if they could work
out the deal they did and now the the
Dodgers like everybody else if they get
any kind of starting pitching and
helping starting healthy starting
pitching I don't think they're done
making moves I think they're gonna make
another move
to help their bullpen and it might be
you know just getting someone like
Bueller back and some stripling back in
the bullpen but the Dodgers went out and
made that move that puts them as the
favorites no doubt especially in their
divisions how do teammates deal with
lack of fumble we saw this with Gary
Sanchez last night and didn't run out a
ground ball could have could have run
out but how is there a team leader who
does something you know the manager is
gonna say something but what would you
do as a teammate or did you have a
teammate who is that guy yeah you know
you first I think your first wait to see
how they react you know whether it's in
the media whether they take ownership
that's the first step and then you know
you based it on the history of the
player and his ability to be accountable
so I think you can't always fire on
somebody you got to come alongside
someone will come alongside the manager
we'll have a talk with them but I liken
it to just even with you know talking to
certain managers when these things arise
and the first thing they say is well he
took ownership first night before and I
wait 24 hours and then either he'll come
into my office voluntarily or we'll have
that conversation just as a reminder and
then it's over
and I think Bobby Cox did that better
than anybody I've ever ever been around
I used to just cringe going how is he
taking that right now and then he'd have
a subtle conversation or a subtle
subtlety to it and it would never happen
again you know I'll never forget him
taking out now this was about as Extreme
as it gets for Bobby but when he went in
out to the mound and I thought he was
taking me out and he actually took out
Andruw Jones from centerfield and that
was the last time that ever happened
with Andruw Jones he felt that he had
kind of you know gone after the ball in
a way that wasn't indicative of Andrew
and it never happened again so it look
it's it's part of the game where it's
162 games and yeah you get a you know
here's a man coming off an injury too so
there's a lot of variables that go into
it that isn't as easy from the outside
looking in when you have some you know
maybe they said hey we need you for 160
- who knows what what the scenario are
is but that's how how it usually gets
handled I'm looking back on your debut
you're 21 years of age you were called
up for the minors and then you pitched
against the Mets at Shea Stadium you
give up a run in the first inning what
are you thinking is a 21 year old at
Shea Stadium facing the Mets in your
debut I tell you it was it was crazy
because this team wasn't very good right
our team's the Braves I got called up I
was excited there was a ton of people I
think it was Tom Seaver day and and
there was a 40-some thousand in the
stands my family was there they brought
up Leo Mazzoni who was the Triple A
pitching coach at the time I remember
looking over asked you know almost
looking for him - what pitch to throw at
times and my first batter was Lenny
Dykstra and I think I hit him on a one -
curveball so I hit my first batter gave
up that first run and you know just felt
myself after that just pitching and when
eight innings yeah eight innings back
then that was we're gonna have this
conversation in ten years where Debut
goes three innings that we're going to
think the greatest thing that ever
happened in the world but won my first
game had a few you know minutes
afterwards to celebrate and it had to go
right to Richmond get all my stuff drive
to Atlanta and then hopefully check in
to Jett my job for the next 20 or so
years and I was able to do that did they
hate you like after you get your first
win no they didn't it was it was I know
you know not a lot of people knew who I
was including the other side because I
remember I remember just you know this
is comments players will make when you
know the Mets were really good and
they'll be asked like how did this kid
come up to beat you I think somebody
said if he was any good he would have
got called upon not that you remember
that not that I remember that not that I
remember
you know specifically uh but yeah yeah
and then you know my next game I went
into the ninth inning against Cincinnati
in a tie game and give up believe a
three-run homer and lost that game and
then I didn't get out of third inning
for three straight seasons so welcome to
the big
I was wondering about this if I ask
Glavine and Maddux to you know help
promote the game you know we're asking
Mike Trout to somehow promote the game
so millions are gonna start watching
baseball you know he's baseball didn't
need to be marketed back then did it not
really no you have more familiar with
players players stayed longer with teams
I mean the biggest out of a body
experience for Glavine and Maddux was
doing the chicks dig the long ball which
still kind of hurts me a little bit yeah
why were you included in that I wasn't a
nike guy that's I mean I'm sure they
would have gone to me because I had all
the power amongst those two but and I
was the only one that had homers at
behind it was brilliant brilliant
commercial envious loved their ability
to get outside their own skin but you
know you think about it make Greg Maddux
never did anything that was the only
thing he ever did you wouldn't know him
walking down the street even today if
you put a collection of Hall of Famers
he's going to be probably it and he was
it was intentional he didn't he didn't
want it and he didn't get out in front
Glavine the same thing we we were you
know I remember doing some cheesy
commercials and I had to have a burrito
in my mouth and be able to try and talk
and it was crazy stuff back then but it
wasn't to your point was it needed I
think today with with as many great
young superstar type potential guys I
think we're losing the opportunity to
see these players with the injury factor
and the latinum on the movement and all
the different teams you know you just
don't see guys Mike Trout has been with
the Angels his whole career and he's
only played in three postseason games I
think all of this would change if he was
in the postseason like we were and
certainly we had TBS which helped but we
were in the postseason all the time so
we became kind of regular when you do it
14 straight years in a row it's it's
gonna be different yeah I always thought
that Maddux was underrated and a lot of
that was that you know he didn't have a
great postseason career but he didn't
really go out of his way to
you know have people say nice things
about him or do features on him and he
was just it's if you can quietly have
350 whatever 350 for whatever it was he
did it you know he did it and he and
purpose gave the horrible interview so
you would stop it I did more interviews
about Greg Maddux than he did himself
and it was when you catch on you go well
that's kind of brilliant if you don't
want anybody to spend five and then it's
with you just say how did you get it
done I was kind of lucky and you know he
just it was terrible
it's one of the worst Hall of Fame
interviewees in the history of the game
and he did it on purpose
it's like Jeter but but Jeter Jeter
released smile
Jeter would give you the impression that
he gave you a great interview there were
no answers there Maddux didn't even give
try to give you the impression that he
really cared about you
hey good to talk to you and have fun the
rest of the season and we'll catch up
all right thanks that's John Smoltz Hall
of Famer for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]